it was once the manufacturing hub of
southern Africa Bulawayo is now running
out of power turning into a ghost town
gone or the streets filled with factory
workers wedge between abandoned
warehouses is a small leather shoe
factory running on a diesel generator
where mashek see banda has been working
for the last 20 years this city is
heading down the drain because the
unemployment is increasing increasing
and president what he was a lot of
people are not employed there's a lot of
Fagor a nobody
everything that's where I said a few
years the strongest survives zip and I
moved to the city in 1980 then shoes
tires steel even beef was exported to
Europe he remembers how then electricity
was not in short supply but abundant
with Zimbabwe exporting it to neighbors
now there's no power at home opening my
fridge I cannot keep enough stock for my
month or week because as you can see
this meat here is already getting bad
but I'll have to eat it I've got no
choice
the mighty Zambezi River that powers the
Kariba hydroelectric dam is running dry
because southern Africa is experiencing
the worst drought in a century as a
result the world's largest waterfalls in
some parts is a slow trickle there's not
enough water to generate power with some
experiencing almost 24-hour blackouts in
November 2017 longtime President Robert
Mugabe was overthrown accused of
mismanaging state assets and failing to
invest in power turning one of Africa's
fastest-growing economies into one of
the continents slowest
Zimbabwe is now on the brink of economic
collapse well these are mostly
pensioners are also nurses teachers
police officers queuing for hours trying
to get money out of the bank in a
country running out of cash the bank
will only allow them to withdraw a
maximum of $20 a week not enough to make
ends meet it's been over a year since
Robert Mugabe left power and many people
here hoped that their circumstances
would change but it didn't to solve the
country's power problem and jumpstart
the economy President Managua is
investing in coal wanting to reopen
decommissioned power plants built 100
years ago by Britain the former colonial
power with Zimbabwe's coffers empty
China is offering to help between two
natural parks home to precious wildlife
they're building open pit coal mining
plants the aim is to bring Zimbabwe back
to its former glory a time when Bulawayo
SPAC thérèse powered the country's
economy attracting Southern Africa's
best workers lured by the prospect of a
prosperous future Nicholas Hawke
al-jazeera Bulawayo